come to our third
day of this U exciting
workshop and uh I
am uh glad to see finally that there
will be a talk without the SW word oh oh
no I added it in
there okay I mean I looked at your work
at your abstract there was no s word in
it so I thought that all of you
thoroughly merited a break from that
okay so our speaker for our first talk
today is Max wisey who is a professor
here at berlay since uh September am I
right since the coming January okay but
I mean morally you are yes moral sure
morally I'm physically here thank you
very
much all righty uh let's get started
thanks for having me
um so this work that I'm going to talk
about today uh is joint work with um my
collaborators during my PhD and post
talk at udub wish include Remy Wong and
Zach patlock both who are here um and
we're gonna be talking about EGS which
is a data structure you may not have
heard of and we're going to do so in
four ways and this is going to sort of
document my journey um from being a you
know PL and compiler optimization you
know uh PhD student and postto and sort
of slowly getting dragged by Remy mostly
uh into uh the world of databases uh so
I hope you will find some interesting
connections uh and maybe some
applications of this work along the
way all right so the four ways we're
going to talk about eaps today is the
first one I'm going to talk about it in
the sort of conventional way um as a
data structure uh and we'll talk about
the various uh ways in which uh they are
used but then as I said I'm going to
sort of uh talk about this journey that
we've uh taken uh in sort of converting
eaps or encoding them into data log in
various forms I'll talk about uh first
an unsuccessful attempt and then a
successful attempt with some big uh
caveats and then I'll talk about some
ideas uh that I have and this is where
the s word may come in uh to sort of
undo some of those caveats and get back
to uh good old data
log all right so but first some
motivation like why are we talking about
EGS what is this data structure used for
so whether we're uh I come from the
compile optimization world and
fundamental thing uh that you want to do
in that context is you know transform
terms you're doing a term rewriting uh
so here's a program uh a simple
arithmetic program a * two divided by
two and we might want to optimize this
to a using some
identities or maybe we have these two
programs and we want to verify uh that
they are equal uh sort of the
predominant technique that you would use
to do this is is term rewriting and the
way that this works is you have a a list
of identities that you know depends on
your
domain uh and and the trick is is you
want to come up with all the identities
uh that you can because some of them are
going to be useful and some of them are
not going to be useful so over here are
and we'll see this in uh in detail in
just a moment these are exactly the
identities that you would need to sort
of do this transformation but I can of
course come up with a lot of true things
that I could say about uh sort of
arithmetic here that are not so useful
or in fact not only just uh not useful
but are sort of will prevent me from uh
doing the optimization that I want to do
so let's see what the happy path looks
like I sort of Applied these identities
from left to right in order oh yes
please you speak about transformation is
yellow
AR you use quality say you can see as
double AR
yes there is some formation the fact on
the the equation is Double Arrow and the
yellow one is onear only one that's
right so yeah so this is exactly right
I'm sort of I am sweeping a little a
little bit of this under the rug for
these identities uh you can think about
them as double arrows but of course
there are transformations that where
both directions don't hold and we'll get
to that a little bit
later okay so let's look at the happy
path um here I'm only going to sort of
invoke these arrows in the One Direction
uh so first we sort of reassociate the
multiplication with the division and
then we can see aha we can perform a
cancellation fantastic and then we can
do another identity and we've optimized
our program
fantastic but let's look at some of the
pitfalls uh in this term rewriting
technique sort of the most Insidious one
is I think this first identity so this
uh says that if you're multiplying by
two instead you might want to do this as
a bit shift uh you know this is a
classic sort of compiler optimization
this is really fast and this is uh can
be much slower so uh in some sense
locally this is always a good idea right
you've taken an expensive operation and
you've turned it into an inexp
inexpensive operation so in fact we're
going to do just that and hooray we've
optimized our program but the problem is
in doing so we've made a locally optimal
choice and we've prevented ourselves
from seeing the sort of globally optimal
uh the globally optimal optimization
here right by taking this turn we we
can't see that the twos line up and then
we can cancel
them other sort of problems are uh you
can get stuck in various kinds of
infinite Loops so of course if we want
to uh reason about commutativity we have
to be very careful because you can of
course commute things back and forth and
end up right where you started and
that's not very
useful and likewise if you apply uh
expansive identities in the wrong
direction uh you can wind up creating
you know terms of arbitrary uh size
which again sort of gets you stuff
process and the last thing I want to say
about this is that you know in this sort
of contrived case these are all bad
ideas uh but it's not very difficult to
come up U with optimizations that you
might want to do where these are in fact
critical these are exactly the optim
optimizations uh that you want to do so
the question when you're writing a
compiler one of the fundamental things
is which transformation do you apply at
which time turns out this is a really
tricky question there's a lot of smart
people that have taken various uh
attempts to answer this question and
we've sort of sidestepped this question
with a technique called equ quality
saturation which allows you to apply all
of these Transformations simultaneously
now it has a cost that we'll get to in a
second um but it does allow you to sort
of sidestep What's called the phase
ordering problem you don't have to uh
you know worry about uh committing
yourself to a wrong decision a wrong
transformation all right and and the the
technique is called the quality
saturation and the data structure that
powers it is called
the yes sorry for no no please please
I'm wondering is the frame consider is
confluent in the sense that there is
only
one let's say normal format you can
reach for the transformation or you can
arrive to different not more
transform piece of information yeah so I
mean the question is about sort
confluent ter Rew writing systems and
like I said there are when it comes to
ter Rew writing of course there's a rich
history in terms you can do complete
your ter teric system if you have a
conent teric system you could sort of uh
you can just go and you can have
confidence that you won't take a wrong
turn um so here we are the the the
method that we are uh using we don't
want to have to manipulate or constrain
the identities that we have uh so we
want to admit uh ter writing systems
that you know are not terminating or not
we want to still be able to do something
with
them all right so let's actually look at
what it what is the egap what is the
data
structure all right and so if you're
familiar with uh the sort of the memo
table data structure used inside the
Cascades query optimization framework
some of this will look a little bit
familiar to you uh despite the fact that
they have sort of independent uh
intellectual uh
heritages okay so what is an Egra it
consists of two parts it has uh e noes
which your sort of the nodes in your
program as and they're grouped into
e-classes equivalence classes all right
and if we want to optimize a program
we're going to start out with a sort of
boring looking egph this egap doesn't it
doesn't record any identities because
each eode is alone in its E-class right
we haven't really done anything
interesting
yet all
right we first I want to Define this
notion of representation which again is
boring now but it will get more
interesting or two uh we say an E-class
represents a term when you can sort of
follow these edges and find that term
inside the egap again that seems boring
but one important thing to note is that
inside our egap the parent child
relationship e noes point to entire
eclasses they don't point to a node
within that class and this sort of
captures the substitutability principle
right if I'm an operator I don't care
you know if you have choices of which of
my argument are if they're equivalent I
don't care which one I take but that's
the whole point of them being
equivalent all right so let's make this
a little bit more interesting by growing
our e let's apply our problematic
rewrite okay this is the one that's a
good idea locally so we we want to do it
but in this particular case will prove
to be a wrong term so the way I'm going
to apply this rewrite to the eaph is I'm
going to look for instances of the left
hand side where X is a
variable and in fact I found one right
here uh so I If by substituting a for x
I can see that hey I've I've represented
this term here okay and where in term
rewriting I would replace this subterm
with the instantiated right hand side
instead I'm just going to add the
instantiated right hand side into the
same
E-class right and so this is a monotonic
process meaning that the the old version
the sort of uh transformed away from uh
version is still represented within this
E-class and in the same E-class is of
course the right hand side of the
transformation as well
so yes please so you have a a bounding
box around two operators yes but not the
descendant of them so this means
conceptually the the operator you just
Link in this inial presentation to The
Operators implying that actually
everything that's descended from them is
part of this
equivalence uh yes I mean so those are
distinct things right you know that they
have some similar arguments but I I I I
I want to be careful not to equate two
and one in this context right the
children of these arguments right so I
need to be careful that I apply the
equivalent only at the sort of root
level of my of my match here I see so
the Box means actually these two subes
rooted at these nodes equivalent that's
what this means yes it means that all
the all of the programs represented in
this E-class here we can see that we
represent exactly two programs are
considered equivalent yes do we try to
make them irreducible in a sense that
like uh if I have if I had another reite
that also uses a one Noe I would always
try to reuse an existing one exactly so
that's one thing that I sort of snuck
past in fact even in our boring uh as we
are doing uh sharing and once you start
uh making your qualities the sharing
becomes very sort of prolific it it
compacts the data structure
quite good
question okay so um now this E-class
with two nodes in it represents two
programs that's all well and good but
that's not very exciting compared to uh
the fact that this notion of
representation propagates up this is
sort of the magic of the data structure
um so this E-class up here despite the
fact that we haven't touched it and it
only contains a single node now
represents two programs okay and that's
because it's uh children one of its uh
child e
classes and so you can sort of see if
you chain up a ladder of e-classes that
have multiple things in them you're
going to start representing
exponentially many prr programs in a
very compact
space and so you know you this sort of
dot dot dot here we can apply the rest
of the Transformations notably we can
apply this transformation that is still
looking for the uh multiplication that
if we did this in a destructive way
would have been deleted right like we
would have gotten rid of this
multiplication so it turns out we can
actually still do this rewrite and we
can do the rest of the rewrites and we
can arrive at our conclusion that our
original program which was sort of this
division node is in fact it winds up in
the same equivalence class as a itself
so that's great that means we've
performed our optimization another sort
of subtle thing um that is a little bit
difficult to notice with all these
arrows going around here is that we have
a cycle in our eaph so this eaph
actually represents an infinite set of
programs and so you can see this
multiplication node it's left child is
in fact the same E-class that contains
it which means that not only does this
E-class have our original program and
our optimized program
but it has all this you know this whole
set of programs a * 1 a 1
so all right and you can uh actually
proceed with this operation until
nothing happens uh in fact when you add
equalities uh many times the data
structure shrinks right and you can get
to a point because you're doing this uh
uh compaction that you're reusing nodes
uh as you as you find them you can get
to a point where you keep applying these
your rights and nothing happens and we
call this saturation this means that
you've learned everything that you're
going to learn um everything that is
derivable uh from the identities that
you've been used using to
reite all right so what we've done so
far is basically verification we've said
like hey you know this thing is
equivalent to this thing but if when
we're doing optimization the question
that we want to answer is hey I I have
an input program give me the best output
program so this is sort of the final
piece of the puzzle and this is a a
phase that uh we call extraction so I
want to say hey my my original program I
know is somewhere in this E-class give
me the best program that is in this
E-class
now um so like I said it represents a
ton of programs we want to make sure
that we don't want to extract a times
one because that's not a we want to
extract
a so we want to pick the one with the
smallest cheapest size um we uh use an
algorithm uh that turns out to be from
uh don can and 6 it's basically shortest
path over
hypertrees um it's a very simple
bottomup algorithm and an I apologize
here's where the uh the s word comes in
um one thing that we've started uh
discussed during this Workshop is that
in fact you can view uh for any
particular eaph it induces uh a set of
polinomial equations and if you just
solve this in the Min plus semi ring you
actually get the um you get the cost of
the cheapest term inside
class did you have a question there yes
you say the best the short what is the
the idea of finding the best yes that's
a great question uh so we've sort of uh
the to for this algorithm for the canth
algorithm which is the same as this we
are using the shortest uh tree size um
turns out in a lot of applications uh
you care about the dag size meaning that
you're you know in your raed program
you're allowed to sort of let bind uh
variables and only count their cost one
time uh that's an NP hard problem uh we
have some encodings into like ILP and
maxat but it's it's it's very sort of
apparent that you uh that c I'm missing
something fundamental about what is in
the theory that allows you to make the
inference that the programs are equival
and how do you deal with that I mean is
it what do you have in so from uh
theory yes so from this system's uh
perspective all of the rewrites that are
are given are aaic right so we're it's
equational reasoning modulo the
uh the axioms that are given to the
system so those are completely trusted
you can easily wind up in a situation
where you're proving one equals two if
are the a equation or do you have semi
conditional equations what do we allow
that uh so so far we've only discussed
uh equational ones we do allow for
conditional ones but we don't have them
we haven't built up the mechanism for
that yet problem deciding that these two
programs are equivalent right yes so you
can use this as a sort of semi- decision
procedure for you know the word problem
or program equivalence uh it doesn't
terminate so that's where you or it may
not terminate uh so that's where this
thank
you um is saturation a necessary
condition for the extraction phase to
what prop certainly not so you could
you're basically uh under you know under
approximating uh the set of provable
equivalences and you you may never
arrive at it at the you know complete
set um so you can always and in fact in
practice because termination is very
frequently never going to happen um you
have to stop early
yes
right okay and so that's the framework
that we call equality satation we could
put it all together where we take in our
initial program that we want to optimize
we chunk it into an eaph and that was
that sort of boring as like eaph that we
saw at the
beginning and then we we turn the crank
we do these rewrites we find the leftand
sides and we add the right hand sides
into those
e-classes and then we perform extraction
and we get our optimized turn around all
right whoopy so the uh the the great
thing about this approach is that it
turns uh optimization which is this you
know or program optimization uh which is
this uh you know there's all these
complicated choices on which rewrite to
apply and you know which rewrites are
even emitted into sort of a two-phase
problem uh one is a which I'll hopefully
try to convince you is a uh you know
basically performance engineering it's a
it's a it's a data log problem this is
actually more more or less running data
log and the second part extraction is a
combinatorial optimization problem when
the cost function like like like
question is simple uh we can do that
simple dous algorithm and when it's not
simple we have to resort to much more
heavyweight techniques uh so that's
basically all I will say about this
combinatorial optimization phase and I
want to dive in a little bit further to
this doe rewrites phase and hopefully
convince you that uh data log is the
right sort of execution mechanism uh to
make this go fast so one quick question
about the kind of equivalences that we
could support with equality saturation
right there might be some equivalences
that introduce new variables right
uh is this allowed because then maybe I
could see that you're not guaranteed to
terminate exactly it's not only allowed
it's essential right even uh consider uh
associativity right X Plus y plus C goes
to X Plus y plus C you know you and from
the data log perspective y plus Z you
needs to be existentially bound in the
head right you don't know that y plus Z
existed beforehand right so absolutely
your termination is completely out the
window as soon as you have uh you know
sort of modestly interesting rewrite
Sy since the operator that you that you
use can be not only to represent let's
say classical algebraic operation but
would be also operation of some
languages or something like that I'm
wondering if you consider some relation
to your framework to graph
transformation and graph
grammas and another question is
sometimes you are not looking for the
best or shortest form of the
form to a sort of normal form will be
the shorter one different
optimization go right um so for in terms
of working with graphs and doing graph
Transformations that is definitely
supported of this framework and I think
that will become more obvious once we
encode this in datal log because uh as
as this was conventionally opposed it it
was very uh it was sort of unnecessarily
restricted to 3D based Transformations
um but once code this in in into data
log you can do the graph transformation
just fine in terms of extracting a
normal form or finding a normal form I
think you've hit the nail on the head
the problem is coming up with a cost
function that you know when minimized
gives you your normal form and that that
is you know very could be very difficult
depending on what your normal question
is I mean I apologize to Stefan for
making this remark right after your
question but I would like to encourage
you Max to remember that we also have a
half an hour for free discussion after
the second talk this morning and if you
feel that some questions are better
address to
them please and blame me blame and do
that all right well then let's get going
uh and get to the data log part but
first I want to explain just a little
bit about how mechanistically this do
REITs part worked before um before the
sort of data log Revolution
okay so this phase is called eatching
and you can think about this is pattern
matching pattern matching modulo
equality so uh here's another eaph um
and we don't have to sort of it's sort
of meaningless it's very
contrived and let's say we are looking
for the pattern F Alpha G of alpha right
and so this is a nonlinear pattern
meaning that we know we've got Alpha
used two times and they better agree in
every one of the matches that we
find so what is a match the the result
of eatching this pattern is we want to
get
substitutions that map the variables in
this pattern to uh e-classes in our eaph
such that when you sort of instantiate
them you get terms that are represented
in the gra right in particular here you
know we don't want to get uh F of one g
of two uh because that's you know that
that doesn't match our pattern all right
so how is this implemented before uh
here's just an example of
all right so let's Implement eatching uh
it follows uh it's it's a top- down
backtracking algorithm if you've ever
written a pattern matcher uh it looks
very similar to that and the E part
turns out to be not that difficult you
just Loop all right so we're looking for
our pattern F of alpha G of alpha well
first let's go over ever E-class not too
bad now in that E-class let's just find
all of the F nodes easy peasy
once we have found an F node we can
start building up our substitution you
can think about this is the this is the
substitution that we'll eventually
return uh and so in the substitution we
want to record that Alpha uh maps to uh
this the the leftand child of the F node
and we also want to write down the root
of the of the pattern match we want to
record where the the match
occurs we're not done yet we have to
check that the rest of the pattern
matches right we want to make sure that
the G of alpha also lines up here so
let's loop loop over the G nodes and the
right hand child and we have to do one
more check here we have to make sure
that hey the child of the G better agree
with that left-hand child of the F that
was the whole point of using
aine and uh if if that's indeed true
then we could deal with
substitution so these data structures
eaps and e- matching are in fact a
really important part of how smt solvers
work eatching is one of the procedures
used to instantiate quantifiers inside
the inside of these tools and this is
more or less the algorithm that has been
used since forever uh to uh to do
quantifier in instantiation now for this
crowd I want to point out something that
uh is sort of
suboptimal uh we it's very easy to show
that this is n s time in this eaph where
I've sort of stacked everything up to be
n wide we just have two Loops over these
uh over these noes but if you sort of
look at the greater structure it's
obvious that there can only be um n uh n
results right so if we think about this
from a data complexity uh perspective uh
it's very
unsatisfying uh so this is basically I
guess what I just said the existing
implementations they are backtracking uh
and they they do have a suite of complex
optimizations that uh more that are sort
of uh getting close to what we might
think of as query optimizations but are
falling short in many important ways the
biggest one that they uh fell short with
were on these so-called equality
constraints so if you're matching a
nonlinear pattern like f of a and a a
again the there was no optimization
based on that right it would just wait
until it matched the whole pattern check
and then
proceed uh and there are no data
complexity results uh everyone has
always known that uh eatching is NP hard
in the pattern size right but if we
think about this as sort of answering
query that's obvious and uninteresting
we want to know uh you know how does it
grow in the Egra
size all right and the last thing I want
to say we we uh we talked about um
syntactic operations over these eaps but
if you come from a program analysis
background like myself there's you know
there's more than syntactic reasoning
right sometimes you want to consider the
semantics of the program in the eaph uh
you know if you want to do arithmetic
for example constant folding you're
going to need a lot of syntactic
rewrites to make that happen you might
want to actually look at the you know
interpret the values in there and do
some semantic
reasoning there's all sorts of program
analyses that I can uh that we that we
can actually uh do inside the egap uh
using the framework uh called E-class
analysis uh that we uh came up with to
to represent
this and I want to speed through this a
little bit because I want to get to the
data log portion uh we come up with this
framework called E-class
analyses and just a brief example of uh
how that works
uh say we wanted to do constant folding
over the
eaph uh the way that you might think of
doing it is you attach an optional
number to each
E-class uh and then as new e noes come
in you evaluate them and when
equivalences are made you merge the two
options right so if we uh we're building
this EG gra from the bottom up we
obviously know two is equal to the
constant two we don't know anything
about a
yet and of course this means we can't
can't say anything about multiplication
or division yet but if for some reason
we learned that a is equal to
two then the uh analysis should be able
to respond to this new equality and you
know react all the way up and say that
aha now we can actually say something
about the multiplication node and
likewise the division
node all right so we have this framework
called the E-class analysis uh we have
framed Us in terms of semilattices um
where you attach one fact from the some
semi latus to each E-class and there's a
pretty simple API to create these the
important part here is that you know the
when you combine uh analysis values
according to equivalence merge that has
to obey the lce
laws all right I'm going to speed past a
little bit of this uh the intervals
example is very neat but I want to give
the data L
portion okay so everything that I've
said uh up to now basically documents uh
the state-of-the-art as of 2021 right we
wrote this paper that is like hey you
know EGS in equality saturation it's
really powerful technique people are
using it for program optimization query
optimization uh and that's all well and
good uh the challenges are we need to
make it go faster it's made program
optimization to this sort of search
problem uh and we need to make if you
want this to scale you need to make that
search go as fast as possible so this is
where uh we're going to look to data log
to sort of speed up that critical
eatching
phase all right
so uh we know that our eatching problem
looks like answering a query and we know
that the database people know how to
answer queries so let's take a first
crack at trying to encode a quality
saturation as data log and see where it
falls
over so again why would we want to do
this if you uh if you sort of think at a
high level equality saturation is a sort
of monotonic process right you know the
whole idea is that you're adding
equivalences and you're never removing
them that was the sort of uh we don't
want to do destructive
rewriting and we know that answering the
the eatching while the while it's the
bottom NE has this sort of query
answering like Behavior right so and
this is honestly uh was enough to get us
started right we were like hey this sort
of feels a little bit like datalog let's
see if we can just sort of smash it into
this
framework all right so how would we do
this well obviously if we want to do it
in data log we're going to need some
sort of tables and schema so let's just
take a crack at it so here's a very
simple we don't even an EG graph yet
let's just start with terms right so I
have uh plus a plus b c and uh the
encoding that we're going to start out
with is just sort of flattening each uh
for each function symbol so for here we
only have the pluses we're going to have
a table where uh the uh there are n plus
one columns where n is the aity of the
function right so the first couple uh
the first two uh columns are going to be
the inputs to uh to each function so
each row is going to be a node in our a
so I think uh this one corresponds to
this one and this plus corresponds to
this
row and we need to sort of uh make up a
value name for the final uh for the
final column right so we're going to say
that uh This plus BC we're going to name
it
BC and that way we have some token to
refer to in the Upper Plus and likewise
we just going to name the value of that
one
ABC okay so this is just is just a
flattening uh of this tree into into the
stable notice we don't have any any e
classes or anything
yet well let's just uh start trying to
do some rewrites let's see what that
looks like uh our working example has
sort of been associativity of plus uh so
let's see how we might write this down
in the data log like thing that has
these terms in
them well so okay the rewrite uh it goes
left to right but because we're doing
datalog I'm GNA do it right to left so
let's just look at the query portion
right we want to look for things that
are an addition with another addition on
the right hand side all right so what
does that pattern look like so this is
the sort of top level here we want an
addition where I'm going to bind X and
YZ I'm G to sort of suggestively name
this YZ and recall I want to also uh
remember where this uh where this
addition is occurring right so we're
going to name this sort of output of
this addition as root and I also want I
want to make sure that this YZ is also
an addition right so I'm going to say
another
uh uh tle in our body is going to say YZ
better be an addition of X and Y all
right so we we've got the query now we
need to uh figure out what the head of
our data log rule looks like and this is
where we need basically tgds uh so I've
underlined and bolded uh the two things
things that are uh need to be
existentially bound in the head you'll
notice that these you are not bound by
the
body uh one thing that uh is tempting is
that because root is the sort of value
of our you know the thing that we're
trying to rewrite it's very tempting uh
to put root here uh but we can't do that
because these are existentially bound we
don't get to name this uh because we're
going to be using an implementation of
data log with uh algebraic data types
right so when you uh put these adts in
the head you only provide uh the inputs
and you you receive the output and it's
going to do this sort of hash consing
for
you uh it's also worth noting that we
don't have you know sort of full
existentials uh the existentials always
appear in this sort of uh position that
in this final position that could be
resolved um from a functional dependency
of the inputs right this is what it
means to be an algebraic data type right
your output is determined by your
okay so oh yes
please ah yes I was gonna ask about
functional dependencies yes uh so we're
trying to uh sort of Bolton and there
have been other works that done this as
well basically the theory of algebraic
data types uh into our data log right
and so the way uh that we are
implementing this is that all of our uh
tables are in fact backed by a map right
and inde
right and so that map is going to not
only ensure that uh you know we have
consistency across you know sort of
calls to the input but it's also going
to be the thing that you know gives that
gives you this existentially um
boundary okie dokie so we just did uh
something but where was the E right like
we did pattern matching uh and I said
you know it was tempting to put this
rout here which would have actually
recorded an equivalence but we didn't do
that right so what we've actually done
is we've just you know added another you
know addition term to our database and
we haven't recorded any relationship
between the input and the output which
is sort of the whole point of equality
saturation right we need to add
equalities so what are we going to do I
mean the erra is an equivalence relation
right so we need something in our data
log that actually uh says something
about
equivalence it's also a congruence
relation but we'll get to that in just a
moment and we also need to do our
pattern matching module equivalents so
not only did we not add any equivalences
we didn't read any uh which uh is again
the whole point of doing maging so we
need to do something uh about this for
this encoding and the really important
thing here is that equivalence is user
exens all right so think uh so think
egds right this notion of equivalence is
something that the user is going to be
building up dynamically sort of at
runtime so how are we going to do this
well our first stab was well equivalence
relation is just a relation you know
it's uh syet symmetric transitive and
reflexive we can write down all of those
things as data log rules so let's just
do that we have an additional binary
relation in our encoding and we need to
ensure that all of our joins become
joins modulo equality right this is what
it means to do eatching right so if we
wanted to do this Jo uh this e join
across this y variable we now need to
split those two variables and join it
across our equivalence relation right
this makes sure that every time we do a
join it's respecting new equality ities
that might appear um from the
user fantastic so this is in fact sort
of the ingredient that we were missing
right so if we wanted to do uh this
example uh associativity of plus we can
get there um we don't have to fully go
through this example but the one thing I
want to highlight is that we are uh in
the body we have an equivalence uh we're
joining across equivalents to do
actually do the eatching and in the head
we have uh an equivalence as well I
think this is a typo this is supposed to
say eek of root and root2 that's you
know sort of was the whole
point one interesting observation to be
made here is that nonlinear patterns
which are in fact uh very interesting
ones uh this one is not so imagine we
had an X here these uh flatten out to uh
a to cyclic patterns right so pretty
simple patterns will very quickly become
pretty complex data log
queries and the final ingredient is the
eaph is a congruence relation not just
an equivalence relation but that's no
problem for this encoding we can just
write the rule again it's a sort of a a
pain in the butt to read uh but this
more or less says exactly congruence
you're saying hey if there are two
pluses where all the inputs are equal it
better be the case that the outputs are
equal to right like that's what it means
the
definition all right we did it we
encoded uh quality saturation in data
log the problem is that this doesn't
work uh it's way too slow uh and I hope
I want to try to get a a get across the
main things that make this encoding too
slow because it's very tempting to do
this uh the biggest uh or one of the big
things is that the equivalence relation
uh will blow up to n squ in size right
if you have N Things or for every
E-class of size n you're going to record
n squ equivalences uh so that's a huge
problem there are uh some tricks that we
try to do to fix it like some folks uh
from the sule data log system uh you can
Implement you of course in just in code
you can use a union find to represent an
equivalence relation in linear space and
they have such a trick that you can uh
have uh basically a union find to
represent a binary an equivalent
solation in your data log program so we
were super excited about that uh because
it does give you that compact
representation the problem is uh for
that implementation it's difficult to
join across it so it turns out if you
join across that equivalence relation it
ends up uh basically expanding it to the
N squared size table anyway so you've
You've Lost Your
compaction uh another tempting thing is
to use uh subsumption so if you're
familiar with subsumption it's basically
a technique uh in datalog to remove
tupal in some sort of way that respects
monotonicity and the reason we were
excited about this is that uh the eaph
under the hood is actually
canonicalizing things so it's UR ing
that uh there are no duplicates and that
when equivalences are made you only hold
on to a canonical
representative and so this basically
means removing all the non-conical
canonical Representatives uh but
unfortunately the data log
implementations of some assumption as of
right now are too
slow uh there's a student at um
University of Washington named dehong
who has basically documented all of
these failed attempts in his master's
thesis it's quite
interesting all right so how are we
going to make this work we going to do
EGS as data log um and make it make it
actually
usable so again what was the problem uh
it was something in the equivalence
relation Not only was too big it was N
squared but we need to be able to join
across it in an efficient way right squ
size etc
etc but more importantly the fact that
we weren't canonicalizing is something
that took us a long time to realize and
is really the key thing that makes the
eaph go so
hopefully this picture uh will relate
what happens if you don't
canonicalize so here is a picture of a
sort of UNC canonicalized egph right
this is you know in in the old egg or
egph as a data structure this is sort of
Mal formed we would consider this Mal
form for the following reason I've
labeled these G nodes with G1 two 3 four
but uh those are only for our purposes
consider these to actually just be the
same operator G all right so the thing
to observe here is that
these two uh G's are not only equivalent
but are identical right they refer to
the same E-class right and you could
imagine this sort of goes on and on
right so this is an e this is an EAP
that has not been canonicalized so
because if you did canonicalize uh these
two G noes they would become
syntactically identical and would be D
duplicated but let's suppose we haven't
done that yet all right um if we don't
do that and we are looking for some
pattern let's say we're you know we have
some pattern F of G of G of X right well
what's going to happen we can we can
still eatch that over this sort of
malformed
eaph but we're gonna get combinatorially
many results right to find F of g g f of
G of G of X I could go this way I could
go this way I could go this way I could
go this way all the way down right and
we can see that you know sort of
uh scaling with the height of this eaph
this blowup is
exponential right whereas if we just
canonicalized it would just be a single
result right so we've really missed
something by not including this in our
data log
coding so the answer is that we we have
to canonicalize right and so this is
where uh if you if you like data log you
should turn away because we're going to
do some really really nasty bad
things uh well we're just going to do
what the egap does we have a union find
to record the equivalence relation the
nice thing about a union find is that
you get this function uh called leader
of X so if you want to figure out
whether two things are equivalent um you
can in fact just look up their leaders
and say hey are they the same thing in
this Union find um and so you can you
can answer this question very very
quickly so what do you mean by leader uh
so the union find U is you know
implemented as a forest leader is
basically what is my current roote in
the UniFi data structure right of course
if two people have the same roote
they're in the same subtree so
there all right so the way that we would
do this in Egra land is the egph is
basically a data structure for
congruence closure that you do you
implement the congruence closure
algorithm we're not going to get into it
here but you know it's not that
difficult to implement and it's very
very efficient so you just explicitly
implement this and uh maintain uh the
canonicalization of the data
structure basically what that means is
that uh whenever X is equal to Y
Whenever You observe this pick one of
them and go replace all the instances of
one with the other in your uh in your
data structure and then you know do any
of the any D duplication that might
result from
that like I said you have to make sure
you do the you you collapse things they
become Sally idal can yes please a
couple of slides to the that you show
the example is what thisly so is the
following what you seem to be doing is
you have ch1 and G2 is being in an
equivalent Class M you them with the
leader means you repl them with one
single no yes F points to that no yes
and the no PL the G1 and G2 the same is
this with G3 and G4 no sorry um the
canonicalization here what uh
essentially just delete one of these
right because these these are the same
operator I've only labeled the one and
two just for our our sake here right so
if you uh canonicalized this then uh
this you know let's start here you know
we have to we have to Pi pick a
canonical representative for this class
and so all of a sudden now this G2
points to here right but G1 pointing to
here and G2 pointing to here means that
these are in fact syntactically
identical so we should D duplicate them
maybe it would help if you explain how
did they end up in there in the first
place how did G1 and G2 end up in that
same class in the first place even
though it's the same G sure it could
have been the case that uh these were
not equivalent
to begin with right you know someone
built up a chain of G's somewhere and
someone built up a chain of G's
elsewhere and then some other identity
which we cannot see equated them and the
again the thing that you have to do when
you canonicalize is that whenever you
get an equation you need to make sure
that this equation I mean the equation
will violate canonicalization right like
every equation means that you know
someone's leader is going to change and
you need to make sure that you know
occurrences of that leader in your data
structure get changed as well so we
arrived here because we didn't do that
second
part nice figure here so uh you
mentioned that the exponential thing is
G1 can lead to G4 and G2 to G3 and the
way in factorization put immedate note
in between them and then she want you to
note and G3 and G4 and that think you
the leader so you actually replace
individual edges for representative call
leader that is found all
equivalent to so you factorize this
graph by having an intermediate layer I
think the the way you get around the I
think what you're describing is maybe a
conceptually equivalent framing what we
actually would do is delete it but we
can discuss this more
offline all
right so yeah the key thing that we need
to do is actually just go in and poke
around in the database the eaph and
change the values uh such that only
canonical values are mentioned this this
is the thing that massively shrinks the
data structure that this is the thing
that we're missing so what do we do well
we canonicalize the database all right
we could use a form of subsumption um
and this is how the subsumption rule
would sort of look we'll just sort of
skip pass that but let's just do what EG
graphs do and actually Implement
congruence
closure what this means is that the
equivalence relation is no longer
explicit right because it has to be
super magical because when you add
something to the equivalence relation
it's going to all of a sudden just do
spooky action at a distance and change
things in your
databases so all of our work that we did
to join across the equivalence relations
well now we can get rid of it because we
because the database has been
canonicalized with respect to this
equivalence relation the semantic
quality becomes syntactic again right so
whereas in our previous encoding you
know to join across these y's we have to
make sure that we join across this
equivalence relation we can actually
write again just the Y here because if
someone had asserted this equivalence
somewhere else we would have gone and
you know mucked with the database such
that these two things became
syntactically
identical all right and so this uh is
embodied in this tool that we both
called egg log it's basically uh just a
data log um plus functional dependencies
and this super magical extensible
equality uh I would like to uh look at
these examples but maybe we'll come back
at the end we have the web demo with all
these nice examples so maybe I'll come
back to this again um but the key thing
that I wanted to uh maybe I'll just look
at one of
them okay so here is uh dat this is just
a very simple example of what data log
plus this sort of uh magical equality
can get you so this is just path
reachability uh hopefully these these uh
these rules are familiar you know edges
or paths and you know paths this is
Transit closure nothing fancy going on
here uh here is our sort of idb we have
Edge one two two and three and five and
six uh now of course if you uh sort of
ran the program at this point there
would be no path from one uh from one to
six but this is the sort of magical uh
equivalence Tule you can just say hey uh
node five and node three become the same
right that means these are identified
and are now completely indistinguishable
to the system right so all references to
one of three or you know to one of these
it's not deterministic which will be
replaced by the other so you can think
about this as sort of now you can answer
uh sort of reachability queries where
you're allowed to merge nodes uh and the
sort of edges you know become combined
as you know would be induced by like the
equivalence relation over
nodes and in fact this
is how to close this tab here all right
that's the right
key in fact this is all it takes to give
you a quality saturation so uh once you
have just basically data log plus
extensible equality you can do
everything that you could have done with
EGS and equality
saturation in in fact uh it's much much
much better uh the implementation and
someone who's implemented both of them
the implementation is much much cleaner
uh and from the data log perspective we
can actually do actual query
optimization now so eatching is cons
considerably
faster uh one thing that has
historically been a struggle for egph
implementations are these so-called
multi-patterns so sort of optimization
example here is that say you want to uh
sort of
co-a these two rewrites so you want to
look for instances of a times B and
instances of a times C where these are
the same a but these don't have these
can appear anywhere there need there
doesn't need to be any relationship
between these two and then you want to
rewrite them
to uh we don't really have to get into
what this
is this was very tricky because this
steps outside of the uh the tree based
Paradigm that EGS were always in but of
course you could write this uh in data
log easy peasy by just having you know
multiple stuff uh in your head so no
problem there uh we also get
incrementality which was you know a
whole research paper on how to do
incrementally matching it just falls out
for free you just do semi naive and
you're done so that's pretty slick
uh this you know we sort of WR this
cheeky paper where we got uh a million x
faster eatching uh because we're these
these uh these complex patterns are very
very cyclic uh and so we just use worst
case optimal joins so we're you know way
ASM totically faster than the naive
backtracking implementation that is
conven conventionally used so it's much
faster it's worth saying a couple things
about functions in equality because uh
when we talk about functional
dependencies in a data log or just what
it means to be a function that's sort of
intrinsically linked to our notion of
equality right like that's what it means
to be a function is that if the inputs
are equal the output better be equal as
well right and so how do we do that in a
world where equality can be you know
changed at any given
moment uh so say you know you have some
uh function f and your egg log program
and a function uh so a function f where
uh F of a is B and F of C is
D well what happens when the user
decides willy-nilly or you know for
whatever reason that a is equal to C
right like now you have an FD violation
uh and these can of course propagate up
these can sort of appear out of out of
nowhere you know F was never Modified by
the user here and yet we have an FD
violation so what happens
um this uh is is very similar to uh like
the data log with lattice uh
implementations where you have the final
uh uh the final column is allowed to be
some lattice value you need to merge
these according to subus laws all right
uh sings also
works okay so this is what we do in egg
log uh this is the technique that we use
in neog as well we allow you when you
special uh when you specify a function
uh you also have to give what's called a
merge expression which gives you the
sort of the lattice law that just tells
you what is the uh what is the meat of
the semil latus that is going to resolve
any functional dependency
violations right so in this example this
is our our goofy Syntax for uh adding a
tupal to the to the database right so if
you add a fo of 75 and F of 74 then of
course the result is going to be F of 74
because our the latus that we're in is
is the mid lat easy
peasy now uh like I said this also works
for conflicts coming
quality
um we also use functions to uh work as
Constructors for our terms right these
are the tables uh that uh you use to uh
you know build trees of arithmetic
Expressions if that's the domain that
we're working
in these are functions right and so they
need a merge expression as well right so
what happens
uh when
you when this function mole which is you
know representing you know some
Constructor in our ASD experiences an FD
violation
well this is a this is sort of the magic
is the lattice that uh can be used to
resolve this FD is in fact the the
mystical magical Union operation right
the way that we can resolve this FD
violation is by asserting a new equality
which then of course then create other
FD violations in some other table right
and this is this is exactly uh
congruence uh closure this is happening
right here and while this works and we
have a proof of this in our paper we do
not have a good understanding of how
this relates uh to the sort of lattice
theory of data log right because this
uh this is a a sort of a dynamic
operation right like while it is sort of
operationally Behaving the same as you
know hey just take the Min or take the
max or take the intersection whatever
you know sort of standard lattice that
you're in this is a a lattice that is
sort of being built on the Fly
corresponding to whatever the union find
is happening under the hood so I think
that's an interesting algebraic question
that we would like to look at going
forward and like I said this is a
just the other thing to note is that um
when you
uh when you resolve
uh the exist itial variable when you're
creating these Ms in the head of your
rule uh you need to come up with some
sort of labeled null right because you
need to say Hey you know in the head of
our rule saying we're multiplying A and
B and that has never been seen before in
our database right we need to come up
with a new name a new label null called
AB uh that we can
uh that that we can then uh down the
road Union with other things right so
the the way that these uh labeled moles
and this Dynamic lattice fit in the sort
of lce theory day log is again something
we don't have a very a clear picture
of another interesting note is that the
system that we built and this is again
sort of by coincidence not not by Design
uh is that this has a very close
relation to the scolum chase right we
have uh egds um and we also I mean it's
a data log so we have tgds um and I say
it's closely related to the SCM Chase
because it's not in fact identical and
this is something pointed out to us is
that um because we are impl in the egds
using this underlying Union find we
avoid the sort of alternation uh
property that uh some sort of
operational views of the chase can have
because when you uh take an EGD you sort
of have to pick one side and transform
the database uh but the having this sort
of persistent ambient Union find
prevents alternation right you you can't
alternate you always have to go up uh in
this Union find lce this sort of
interesting observation
okay so just a quickly review uh the
good things about this uh spooky data
log implementation is that it actually
works right this allows us to implement
uh equality saturation which you know is
a technique that people are are really
using in the programming language world
uh on top of something that looks pretty
much like a data log uh it has the fast
congruence so it has fast queries Alla
data log it has fast congruence Allah
the sort of original Egra implementation
in it's the exact alith it's the you
know conure alith from like
195 it has these ni functions modu
quality which uh despite not really
understanding how that they uh relate to
sort of lattice Theory uh of of data log
they do they do in fact work
out this allows us to sort of get the
E-class analysis uh system that we
talked about
before the downside and this is where
you know definitely some future work is
required and you know hopefully this is
somewhat interesting to this crowd is
that there we've lost our ability to
refer to specific terms right and this
is actually somewhat important the the
the way that uh the egg log system works
is by when you equate two things it
makes them indistinguishable right it is
literally impossible in the system to
ever distinguish between these two
things again and this makes it very fast
but there are situations where you might
want to refer individually to terms with
in an equivalence class and we've lost
that ability
here another way to think about it is we
only have families of terms now there's
no such thing as an individual
ter uh I've mentioned sort of this uh
some of the underlying semantic
questions and a big thing that I would
like to work on going forward is that
obviously uh this encoding that we' just
presented is limited to a single notion
of equality right it's super duper
specially baked in what if you want to
to uh work with other relations of terms
maybe it's two separate equivalence
relations maybe you want to work with
something that is a partial order but
not necessarily symmetric right maybe
you want to work with a sort of indexed
equivalence relation maybe you want to
do modular arithmetic where you know you
have equivalence mod 3 equivalence mod
mod 10 or whatever right these are
things that sort of the naive data log
and coding would support right you just
make another equivalent solation you can
write all those rules we've lost the
ability to do that in this sort of
performance system
all right so I think I'll just stop
there and we can uh take some
questions uh thank you Max I think uh we
have time for one or maybe two questions
but I would like
to postpone the weight here questions
for
the discussion
after Jo so please
Boris
Kristoff uh who goes first Kristoff uh
can you comment if you have thought
about this um does all this play well
with magic sets have you thought about
this uh not only uh yes but it it will
become essential um the uh think so
because all these additional Health
predicat introduced there they should be
interesting in the C right so I think
magic sets uh and the sort of uh demand
transformation which is sort of
extension of that uh are going to be
essential for controlling the because we
termination is out the door right
because we have these tgds uh like we're
doing we're more or less doing the Chase
and so the demand transformation I'm
seeing in magic sets I'm seeing as a way
to sort of control the expansion of the
database right if from the egph
perspective you know there's this
mystical magical egap that you're never
going to reach that has all of the
equivalences that you'll ever want but
if you know for in the real world and
you have to stop eventually right now
we're making a decision on you know
which equivalences are we you know
considering the juicy ones that we
actually want to you know find our
optimized program in and uh know any
sort of uh tool that allows us to work
with the control flow of data log so
it's magic sets you know any sort of
top- down demand transformation I think
is going to be essential to achieve
that is that okay if you postpone your
okay so we're taking of
uh but I'm going to hit you over the
head with that uh that Bell in 25 to 27
minut